[Música]
si en 2020 respaldamos la cultura cuenta
en 2021 con esa defensa porque en lugar
de normalizarse con protocolos el sector
está retrocediendo a nuevos
aplazamientos y cierres ejemplo son los
premios grammy de la música postergados
de enero a marzo si bien más inquieta
que el principal experto en enfermedades
infecciosas anthony fauci haya apuntado
al otoño estadounidense como posible
fecha de reapertura de salas de
espectáculos y artes escénicas eventos
populosos que igual sufren en uruguay y
bolivia de estar en lo cierto fawzi es
más de año y medio de desempleo para
estas disciplinas que en la nación
uruguaya si regresaron en agosto y aún
así aún siendo vanguardia de conciertos
obras y danzas están acorraladas entre
el gasto del aforo mínimo y el cese
total la cancelación del carnaval el más
largo del mundo no les ayuda como
tampoco a los artesanos bolivianos cuyo
sustento depende de los trajes y adornos
folclóricos de las fiestas ya no hay
ingreso para nosotros ni uno ni un
centavo desde porque ya no bailan todas
ciertas cancelados ya estamos nomas
sobreviviendo en este panorama friendly
which es un oasis la cita amical que es
placer asegurado pese a que en europa y
latinoamérica nos quede lejos esta
autora de éxito sin libro desde hace
tres décadas con poco autobombo en
netflix hoy la conocemos por ser la voz
corrosiva de esta miniserie documental
en la que martin scorsese nos
personifican nueva york con ella no es
la primera vez en 2010 en public
speaking ya había generado este tipo de
charla con la protagonista pero aquí
scorsese no para ver reír ante una amiga
que es verbo rápido humor y pasión sobre
una ciudad que ya no existe para
leibovitz nueva york son sus vacaciones
infinitas es testigo de sus cambios al
tiempo que ella paso de taxista a
fichaje de andy warhol y también
comentarista reconocida y esa testimonio
neoyorquino lo usa para ir por sus
derroteros sin perdonar ni a turistas ni
a alcaldes
cuentan con ella para pensar repudiar a
la masa e ir de fiesta pero no para
consultas de compra y venta en eso es lo
peor
[Aplausos]
[Música]
y con el streaming fortalecido en
pandemia otros tres anfitriones hacen
gala de sus poderes dos en sentido
literal porque son wanda y misión
la pareja de superhéroes no sólo dispara
la adrenalina como primera serie de
marvel en disney blast llevando a la
plataforma las gemas del infinito sino
que bajo la estética de sitcom de antaño
tipo la hechizada borda una fórmula
humorística no exenta de misterios los
actuales elizabeth olsen y paul bettany
ganan impulsando la fase 4 de emshi y
ahondando el multiverso y una realidad
bien particular para vision
los guiones de jacques y fer sabes ella
y su equipo han escrito algo increíble
un rompecabezas realmente hermoso
elegante e intrincado mi personaje se
usó como una especie de ancla emocional
yo tal vez no era la pieza más divertida
pero el mejor regalo es que pude
interpretar todos los solos y colores
que tenemos en las películas de marvel
el endeavour af
el último poder lo ostenta aún más sí
porque es omar sí y además de lucir lo
como mega estrella francesa ahora lo
exhibe también como gentleman lupa fuera
del país se desconoce que axel ni para
es un personaje un maestro del disfraz a
la altura de sherlock holmes pero esta
serie funde esa ficción literaria con la
identidad de assange que bajo las
sombras de accem sobrelleva con ingenio
su vida y la memoria de su padre con ese
toque de ladrón de medio justiciero de
carácter tierno y aquí también crítico
del racismo como demostró en la parada
de metro del louvre o maxi es un
entretenido lupa del que si no te fijas
bien no lo verás
matones
la foxista el juego
pasamos los chistes como acciones
el filamento yo panas
[Música]
extraño óptico sur
parís es distinta
mi papá dijo
muy paquete
por la serie de la venta de los libros
de la saga iniciada por móviles lo plan
en 1907 se han disparado pero si buscan
refugio extra les invitamos a estos
relatos de su contemporáneo muscle prost
en unas confesiones de juventud sobre
sus deseos y su homosexualidad
clandestina que permanecieron hasta
ahora ocultos mientras que proust quiso
olvidarlos
silvia pérez cruz potencia lo que llama
género imposible una farsa que está
formada por 13 composiciones que
dialogan con la poesía la danza el cine
y el teatro si sin ellas ya era un
magnetismo natural propio de quien posee
esa esencia en este álbum es poderío que
se multiplica para llenar huecos y sacar
de estos huecos la fragilidad íntima lo
que no vemos casi como lipán gracias por
su compañía y cuídense
[Música]
trompeta